[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo les quiero pedir un gran favor
quiero que levanten la mano las personas
que tienen más de 40 años
ok
ahora quiero que levanten la mano las
personas que tienen más de 30 años
creo que levanten la mano las personas
que tienen más de 14 años
buenísimo
sucede algo
tenemos algo positivo y algo negativo de
esto que les acabo de decir
lo positivo es que me hicieron un favor
sin conocerme y eso es lo que hacen los
seres que yo más admiro en la vida
pero lo negativo
es que mi charla era para niños
entonces no sé qué hacer
porque yo venía a hablar con niños para
que nos riéramos un rato para que
compartiéramos
entonces pues ni modos no puedo hacer la
charla
no mentiras les voy hablar más bien de
otro tema entonces que de pronto a todos
nos puede gustar
les va a hablar de viajar
creo que la gran mayoría nos gusta
viajar
y yo empecé a viajar esa foto la tomé
hace 11 años empecé a viajar no porque
me gustaba viajar yo empecé a viajar
porque cuando estudiaba fotografía dije
debe ser increíble tomarle una foto a un
delfín rosado y me fui para la amazonas
y la foto del delfín rosado nunca
existió
porque es muy difícil y los que han
estado allá saben que es muy complicado
pero si entendí
que la fotografía era una excusa
realmente para viajar que detrás de los
viajes hay un montón de cosas más que
valen y que aportan
y así fue como es y viajar
empecé a viajar y ha sido un gran
aprendizaje
conociendo viviendo disfrutando
lastimosamente en el año 2011 tuve un
accidente un accidente que me cambio
para el resto mi vida
yo practicaba este deporte y tuve un
accidente en el que me atrapó y un bus y
estuve en cama varios meses
y ese accidente me dejó unas secuelas y
los médicos me decían que yo no iba a
poder volver a trotar a correr a saltar
a jugar fútbol hacer cualquier cosa que
fuera impacto así que mi vida se alteró
y cambio y justo en ese momento de mi
vida
estaba mal económicamente y tenía que
seguir adelante así que seguir
trabajando trabajaba en un restaurante
que tenía seis pisos y fueron miles de
veces en las que me tocó quedarme
sentado porque no podía seguir caminando
si la vía siguió y yo me adapté me
adapte a mi condición
pero también entendí
que yo no viajaba
para escapar
yo viajaba para volver
para volver y compartir
porque ahí está la ciencia
viaje por muchos países era mi sueño y
fue afortunado y lo logré
había que compartirlo
seguir viajando fui a culturas muy
diferentes a las nuestras donde todo
cambia los olores la comida la gente
seguir viajando conocía más culturas
diferentes que me llenaban me
enriquecían como ser humano
estuve en el primer mundo también
aprendiendo un poco de ellos
en países que se quedaron quietos en el
tiempo
en la bella parís que es la ciudad del
amor y así
pero me di cuenta que hacía falta algo
y era que yo no me conocía a mí mismo
y para conocerme a mí mismo
tenía que conocer a mi patria
porque porque es que uno es todo lo que
lo rodea y uno se construye a partir de
todo todo lo que lo afecta en la vida
así que decidí volver a colombia y
gracias a una fundación en donde soy
profesor empecé a compartir con la gente
por acá en cundinamarca cerca y empieza
a ver la pluralidad de nuestro país y la
riqueza de los seres humanos que tenemos
pero para ese aprendizaje
yo necesitaba a alguien que llevará el
timón
y creo que ellos son los que llevan el
y aprovechando el sueño de la guajira la
guajira fue la que me abrió las puertas
al principio
y descubrí que los niños
eran chiles me iban a enseñar
absolutamente todo
todo porque los niños
tienen más sabiduría que cualquiera de
nosotros
tienen una inocencia única y tienen algo
tan mágico y es que no juzgan
porque ellos siempre se ven como iguales
y yo me preguntaba por qué me relaciono
así con los niños qué es lo que hace qué
exista este este vínculo porque es que
de verdad yo flipo con los niños más me
gusta estar más con los niños que con
los adultos
y quería entender por qué pasaba eso
y entendí
que había sido por la niñez que yo había
tenido
no diría que fue una niñez desastrosa
porque no fue así
pero si tuvo muchos momentos negativos
muchos
como también tuvo unos positivos
pero me tardé muchos muchos años
entendiendo
que era la parte positiva
y entendí
que yo haya tenido que vivir así esa
niñez tal cual
para hacer lo que es hoy en día
y para poder conectarme así con ellos
ellos me han enseñado absolutamente todo
y creo que en ellos está la salvación
ellos me han enseñado a recorrer el país
y entenderlo y disfrutarlo de una manera
única
en donde no hay diferencias como él
un niño que tiene una diferencia pero
que sigue siendo feliz
creo que
si yo no hubiera pasado por todas estas
situaciones cuando fui niño no hubiera
llegado a entender lo que realmente cada
uno de ellos me estaba enseñando
si hay algo que yo amo hacer
es compartir pero compartir anhelo
nuestro país es un país que vive muchas
injusticias que
en donde llego hay maltrato ahí hay
cosas que ni siquiera yo puedo
dimensionar pero yo siempre he pensado
algo y es que ya está bueno de compartir
todo eso toda esa maldad porque no
compartir anhelo esperanza felicidad
porque creo que ese granito que vamos
aportando va construyendo y va motivando
a más personas a que también sigan
siendo así
les voy a contar de todos esos viajes
dos historias muy puntuales
ella es terremoto
buenas y le podéis yo porque la verdad
la niña da yo los amo pero hasta cierto
punto porque terremoto tenía una energía
descomunal terremoto vive en la frontera
entre la selva del perú y la colombia en
un corregimiento que se llama puerto
arica
le dicen puerto mosquito porque es
impresionante la cantidad de músculos
que haya y si que tienen problemas allá
de desigualdad de abandono del estado de
violencia de narcotráfico de abusos
pero ella angélica se llama que tiene 11
años
angélica me enseñó la importancia
de entender nuestro entorno
me enseñó
qué
todo lo que nos rodea
es lo que nos hace es lo que nos hace
seres humanos
y que si yo no estoy en armonía con ese
entorno
no va a lograr salir adelante
fueron tres horas el día que pasamos con
ella caminando yogur ea ya una semana
pero esas tres horas creo que me
marcaron y me marcaron de por vida y le
agradezco el universo que ella haya
aparecido y lo más bonito es que me sigo
hablando con ella
porque hay una persona en la comunidad
que tiene un celular y hay una parte de
la pequeña comunidad donde coge la señal
y hace poco estuve en otro país y me la
llevé a viajar virtualmente aprovechando
la tecnología
es este personaje que viene acá
se llama irene
irene tiene 7 años
irene es de una comunidad indígena que
se llama cagua en una comunidad llamada
guacara
en donde para llegar de es llegar hasta
mi atún tomar una lancha una hora y
media y luego caminar durante dos horas
y media por la selva con el agua hasta
acá siempre
y así fue mi recorrido caminando fuerte
exhausto habían muchos moscos humedad de
todo cuando la selva te abruma cuando
empezó a desaparecer
y empecé a ver la comunidad
ella fue la primera persona que vi
y estaba sonriendo y jugando
y yo lo único que hice se me olvidó mi
cansancio tiré de la maleta y me puse a
jugar con ella y no fueron uno ni dos ni
tres sino como cinco días en los que lo
único que hicimos fue jugar
irene no habla ni una sola palabra del
español ni una sola
y fue la que me dejó la elección diría
más grande más más grande que hay
irene me enseñó
algo que realmente todos deberíamos
tener muy latente me enseñó a ser feliz
pero me enseñó a ser feliz desde acá
desde adentro
a amarme a respetarme a valorarme
para poder luego aportarle a otros más y
ayudarles en ese camino de la felicidad
porque si hay algo que debemos tener
claro es que primero es debemos sentir
plenitud acá y acá
para poder ayudar
y ahora les voy a decir algo ustedes
estos niños estos viajes
me ayudaron a revelar mi vida y gracias
a eso
he tratado de ayudar a revelar la de
otros
yo quiero que ustedes se pregunten de
verdad cómo están rebelando sus vidas
como lo están haciendo y piensen siempre
va a haber algo negativo y algo positivo
depende de nosotros ver cómo lo
utilizamos porque recuerden algo
la vida para ser feliz
y sólo hay una
pero la felicidad no es felicidad si no
se comparte
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]